white people when you go on vacation to
like a beach or something
don't go back to work and go up to your
black co-worker and be like ooh look
i'm almost as dark as you
[Applause]
we hate that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
don't do that
we hate that you really hate that we
hate ooh almost dark you will never know
what it's like to be in this skin and
you know what every time you say it
secretly we wish you get fired we just
hoped
there's no real black stuff happening to
you like yo i'm almost as black as you
bob you're fired or
yeah hope you get sick of sale what's up
wow okay that's that's pretty intense
we hate it don't do it yeah but i like
to i have to tell uh you know let people
white people know about these things
because uh i i'm shocked it's like 2018
and there's a lot of white people who
don't have like a good black friend
that's the problem right there you know
i hate when i go i go to like one of my
white friends parties and i get there
and i'm the only black person it's like
really just me that that's all you and i
want to leave but then i go oh i feel
bad if i leave and another black person
shows up and they'll feel the same
disappointment that i'm feeling right
now
so you got to stick it out you got to
check it out and just okay
make some black frizz but you know i but
i get that why black people don't have
white friends i get that i do know
a lot of trust has been broken
a lot of trust has been broken like like
we got like baby steps you know at least
start out with like a puerto rican first
you know
[Laughter]
ease your way into having a white friend
yeah yeah race is huge right i mean
every you know if you notice like
everything
every subject in this country we talk
about somehow it goes back to race you
know they wouldn't they even divide a
race and like the poverty levels you
know like they were saying like there's
a just a disproportionate number of of
african-americans who are below the
poverty level compared to white people
who are below the poverty level right
and i'm like what the heck who cares
poor is poor yeah broke is broke it's
not like black people are going oh i
picked up some some extra hours last
week
keep this stuff i'm almost white poor
[Applause]
what are you watching on tv these days
are you watching i mean are you seeing
that reflect like do you want to watch
do you watch a lot of uh i don't know
reality t i want you know what i had to
do again race i i was hooked on uh
investigation discovery i was watching
you know that's all murder all the time
those murder shows i love those i love
them but you know what i noticed i was
like hey
how come they ain't murdering any black
people on these shows
there's a lot of white murderers but not
a lot of black like so what our murders
aren't sexy enough
nobody cares about our murder right
right right and so then what bet did bt
they have a whole uh uh block a whole
block of black murders fatal attraction
right so i started watching that and i
was like there you go that's good here
we go got some black murders
good black murders
and then all of a sudden it hit me was
like
this chick kind of looks like my cousin
i can't
i said i can't let me go watch these
white people get hacked up
[Laughter]
strangest complaint i think i've heard
in a long time we'll take a break much
more with juana's psyche stick around